now I see why you guys sent this video
my way hey everyone I'm Abby sharp
welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video we'll be taking another
look at Sarah's day before we get into
the video we're going to play a little
game called Abby's daily hunger crushing
combo so I've had a very busy day and
I'm hitting that 3 P.M energy dip and I
feel like I need a little something
something so let's build a Hunger
crushing combo so I've got some really
yummy crunchy mango chips for some
antioxidants and some extra fiber we got
some pistachios here for some healthy
fats plus some Fiber and some extra
protein and I'm gonna have a bill bar
puff for my protein as you guys know I
love Bill bars because they come in a
ton of different tasty flavors and they
taste like real chocolate because they
are made with chocolate but they pack a
ton of protein like this bar right here
has 17 grams amazing so this is the
perfect hunger crushing combo snack to
get me to the dinner Time Rush without a
hangry meltdown
um so if you watch how built by yourself
check out my link in the description and
use my promo code abbysharp15 to get 15
off of your order
uh looks like someone else needs a snack
too and you can pause the screen or look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always feel free to skip this video if
it is not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me over
on Tick Tock and Instagram at Abby's
kitchen so for those of you guys who are
long time subbies of mine you are
probably no stranger to Sarah's day as I
have reviewed not only what she eats in
a day but also more recently her health
app sunny I honestly thought we were
done here but judging by the
overwhelming volume of emails and DMS
related to some of her more recent
problematic content I was clearly wrong
so let's take a look at one of her more
recent days of eating almond milk
Barista almond milk I'm actually going
off the oat milk that I used to buy it
is really full of like vegetable oil I'm
trying to make everything I eat a lot
more like basic and Whole Foods and
we're already off to a not so great
start I first want to highlight the
contradiction of saying that you're
trying to eat more Whole Foods while
simultaneously holding a curtain of
almond milk which by the way is not a
whole food and it's definitely
considered a processed food since
there's about two percent actual almonds
in most Major Brands and I don't think
that there's anything wrong with
consuming processed foods including
almond milk I love almond milk but it's
just always ironic when Wellness
influencers demonize them while
simultaneously like sharing their recipe
for a protein smoothie with protein
powder spirulina nut butter coconut
water and frozen fruit which are all
incidentally processed this is why it's
actually unhelpful to categorize Foods
as good or bad because it's absolutely
never black and white many processed
foods are actually quite nutrient dense
accessible convenient and in some cases
actually safer for consumption but
anyways back to it when it comes to oat
milk it is true that some oat milk
brands have like sunflower or canola oil
in them to improve the texture which
will naturally alter their fatty acid
profile and we hear a lot of hoopla in
the Wellness Community about avoiding
seed oils because they allegedly
increase inflammation due to their
omega-6 content however the larger body
of high quality evidence suggests that
omega-6 fats don't actually have a
significant effect on inflammation and
some research even suggests that they
may even reduce the risk especially when
in combination with Omega-3s which
canola oil and sunflower oil also have I
also want to point out that even though
the almond milk that Sarah swapped for
her usual oat milk doesn't contain
vegetable oil it does contain the
emulsifier sunflower lecithin which
ironically also contains omega-6 fats so
we end up getting in our own way when we
hyper fixate on ingredients and read
into misinformation which in the grand
scheme of things doesn't make or break
our health especially if we're consuming
just like normal amounts so unless
you're consuming gallons of oat milk
every single day and not much else I
don't see any major cause for concern I
just feel like I was just surviving
especially with food like I would have a
big breakfast and then all day I just
like ate a fox's plate or like I have
four muesli bars as a lunch I just lost
my passion for help so sick of ubereats
and I'm just sick of not giving myself
time to even like have lunch or make
myself lunch like as mothers we
sacrifice so much time for our kids that
like just in the next two weeks I'm like
I'm gonna give myself 20 minutes every
lunch time to like prepare myself for
lunch and enjoy it I can totally relate
to this sentiment and have been there
many times myself and I feel like
oftentimes us Mamas become Martyrs for
our children and we sacrifice so much of
our basic needs and well-being to make
sure that our kids have everything that
they could possibly need but then at the
end of the day you just end up pouring
from an empty cup and while I know it's
really easier said than done you have to
make sure that you have your own oxygen
mask on before you can put it on your
kiddo and sometimes this really just
means getting down to the basics of
eating three meals a day like having a
shower moving your body and getting a
good night's sleep so I totally feel for
Sarah and definitely understand the
struggle because even that feels like an
impossible task for me but small
sustainable changes really do go a long
way and I think that committing to just
like 20 minutes a day to prepare a lunch
is a very reasonable goal and it
honestly doesn't have to be a big ordeal
it can be as easy as like opening a can
of tuna for a sandwich or boiling an egg
to have with a side of veg and crackers
getting that fuel in the tank is
essential otherwise it's just a
fast-tracked way to burn out I got on
this really good Tick Tock algorithm and
it was all about like additives in food
and like vegetable oils in your milk and
it like it just sparked that old Sarah
in me of like wanting to eat really
healthy again not in a restrictive way
just in like a really wholesome simple
way leave it to tick tock to scare you
from something as benign as oat milk
also Tick Tock is the most unregulated
dumpster fire of nutrition bullet I have
ever seen so let's please not believe
everything we see from a 30 second Tick
Tock clip there's also so much
misinformation and fear-mongering around
food additives online which I actually
debunk in my food label Series right
here and while I don't know the
specifics of the information that Sarah
was exposed to other than the vegetable
oils in general most food additives are
highly regulated and safe to consume in
doses present in the foods that we eat
and if you ever hear that bullet advice
not to eat ingredients that you don't
recognize or can't pronounce please
unfollow that person immediately because
with that logic you'll probably end up
turning down products that have
ingredients like ascorbic acid or
calciferol which are just synonyms for
vitamin C and vitamin D respectively and
like I said with vegetable oils we don't
have evidence to suggest that they are
selling that we need to completely avoid
so on the one end I get that being stuck
in a motherhood rut and seeing health
information online can motivate you to
like jump start your Wellness routine
but it should ultimately be about
self-care and nourishing yourself in an
accessible and sustainable way not about
controlling your food or fueling fear
around minute aspects of what you're
eating ultimately swapping oat milk for
almond milk is not going to make a
significant dent in your Wellness
Journey the same way that something like
Sarah's goal of prioritizing a 20-minute
lunch to nourish your body will I'm
kick-standing Sarah's day Wellness week
if you go to my website sarahsday.com I
have a bunch of free PDFs that we've
made for you guys just the objective of
this Vlog and these two weeks of
Wellness is to inspire you guys to do
something that improves your sense of
willing you have three meal plans I'll
put them up here that you guys can
access and it kind of gives you an
inspiration or like it kind of gives you
an idea or inspiration of like what you
can eat in the week to just like mix up
your diet I love a good freebie so of
course I had to check out what Sarah's
Wellness week was all about and I
actually really liked the meal plans
because they served more as like food
inspo rather than prescriptive advice
they also have good variety and cater to
different preferences so for example
she's got a vegan meal plan as well as a
family meal plan with lots of options
for breakfast lunch dinner snack and
dessert I also love how one of the PDFs
literally focuses on how to fill up your
cup with different prompts to check in
with yourself set intentions and
prioritize your basic needs like
hydration sleep movement hygiene and
doing something that you love and I
actually really love this simple and
accessible approach to Wellness because
I feel like the wellness industry has
quickly capitalized on a very
superficial version of what it means to
be well wellness and self-care isn't
just about having like a 20-step
skincare routine wearing a matching set
and going to an expensive pilates class
sometimes it really just comes down to
the boring non-aesthetic Basics I want
my basic hot dog and also tackling the
difficult and uncomfortable stuff in
between and that might mean going to
therapy and having like an ugly cry or
focusing on your financial Wellness or
setting boundaries in your relationships
and in Sarah's case it means taking a
few minutes to prepare a meal so that
you can have enough fuel in the tank to
be super mom being well is really about
your needs and what makes you thrive it
is not defined by social media or an
influencer's version of wellness it's
also not about checking off an extensive
to-do list of Wellness activities if it
leaves you feeling stressed and depleted
so I love that Sarah's Wellness week
turns the tables and encourages you to
reflect on what you need rather than
dishing out this really strict
prescriptive advice of what you should
be doing to be well
foreign
[Music]
this is what I've been loving like a
berry porridge with maple syrup and
yogurt this looks like an amazing
breakfast to really help power you
through a day of mommy duties we've got
tons of energizing carbs from the oats
lots of staying power from the protein
and the yogurt and the healthy fats from
the nuts plus topped off with some
berries for fiber and micronutrients
looks awesome usually on Saturdays I go
to this really intense class it's like a
full body like CrossFit style class but
yeah I woke up at like six and I was
like it's just like that would not be
honoring my body today you know so like
the whole thing with Wellness week is
like truly listening to your body and
doing what it needs that doesn't mean
forcing yourself to like go to the gym
every day and like be disciplined this
girl is speaking my love language carbs
It's My love language I am all for
moving in a way that makes your body
feel good but you certainly don't need
to go balls to the walls and like hit up
an intense hit class to reap the
physical and emotional rewards of moving
your body some days all you really need
is like a gentle stretch or like a light
walk maybe even nothing at all nothing
at all
ultimately your body knows best so I
applaud Sarah for honoring herself
practicing some self-care and not
forcing herself through a strenuous
workout when her body just isn't feeling
great
[Music]
thank you
oh my gosh this is like so invigorating
making lunch like I literally never get
to eat lunch we love a tasty green salad
for lunch and this one has the works
we're getting crispy tofu for some
plant-based protein some carbs from the
quinoa and a mix of veggies but I will
say as a busy Mom myself even this salad
would feel like a tall order for me
especially with all like The Chopping
and cooking involved so to really
streamline this process I would probably
just grab like a pre-made salad mix add
in like some rotisserie chicken a can of
tuna or canned chickpeas for protein and
like serve it with five minute couscous
pita or crackers on the side either way
though I think it's great that Sarah's
staying committed to her goal of
preparing herself lunch and making
things easier for herself by prepping
some ingredients ahead of the time we
play a game of like what's healthy food
and what's not so healthy food like
sometimes food what is a healthy food
um
pineapple yes what is maybe a not so
healthy food or sometimes food chocolate
yeah sometimes
watermelon is healthy do you want me to
have a go okay our healthy food is
broccoli and sometimes food is hot chips
now I hope this is
kind popcorn yeah it's okay but like
what's help what's really really healthy
bananas yes and what's a sometimes food
what can you just have yummy yes lollies
now I know what all your DMs were about
I totally understand that Sarah had
nothing but good intentions with this
innocent seeming game but this approach
can very quickly backfire and actually
do the opposite of fostering a balanced
healthy relationship with food in fact
we have research showing that children
who are restricted from certain foods
are actually more likely to over consume
these Foods when they do have access to
them which is what happens when kids
grow up where they go to parties or they
hang out with their friends Etc and even
though I don't get the sense that Sarah
is actively restricting these foods from
her kids as she's literally just kind of
made cupcakes with her son but even the
language that we use around food can
make a huge impact
I also just quickly want to elaborate on
this a bit because I've had a lot of
time to think about it and I also don't
want to leave parents unsure of what to
do instead I also spoke to a ton of my
Rd colleagues who work with kids
specifically and we all agreed that it
is absolutely not age appropriate or
arguably appropriate ever to categorize
Foods as healthy I know sometimes Foods
feels a little more moderate but it's
still grounded in diet culture and
restriction so what should you do
instead just cold foods what they are
like call it a [ __ ] lollipop not a
treat okay maybe not [ __ ] lollipop
but you get what I'm saying like call it
a cupcake not bad or something that they
can only have some of the time call it
broccoli like just broccoli not a black
or white Health Food of course some
foods are more nutritious than others so
if you want to teach your kids a little
bit about nutrition I really like my
colleague kids eaten colors approach so
talk about what a food or food group can
do for our body you know it gives us a
strong brain it helps fight off sickness
heal from Cuts make our hearts strong
you know ultimately nutrition is nuanced
and boxing Foods into black and white
categories no matter what you call them
is teaching diet culture at a very
sensitive vulnerable age no hate to
Sarah but I just don't want other
parents who are watching to think that
this game is a good idea to teach kids
about food kids will learn that if Mom
doesn't want me to have the lollies and
the chocolate they must be really really
special and good really really really
ridiculously good looking well the
broccoli she's like really really
pushing hard must be gross or there's
something wrong with it why would she
care so much calling foods that some
kids may not really like healthy teaches
kids that healthy means gross it's no
different than when us adults have a
forbidden bad food list we just kind of
want them even more and as I discussed
in my video on the division of
responsibility raising children to have
a healthy relationship with food isn't
about controlling what or how much they
eat it's actually about creating
complete food neutrality and not
praising or shaming one food Choice over
another our kids are born intuitive
eaters so in order to honor and preserve
those skills we need to provide a
supportive environment that allows their
natural self-feeding and food regulation
capacities to thrive and that just can't
happen when you set limitations rules or
even demonizing language around
sometimes Foods here's the thing about
Wellness week it's not just about eating
100 healthy it's about enjoying your
food like for me it's like 80 20. so I
know that the 80 20 rule is essentially
a synonym in dye culture for eating in
moderation which I think was the
intended theme of this video given its
title and I agree that eating in
moderation is key as we still want to
make sure that we're leaving space for
foods that not only nourish us
physically but emotionally as well so I
like that Sarah's intention with
Wellness week is prioritizing self-care
by eating regular meals and focusing on
nutrient dense foods while also leaving
space for eating cupcakes with her
family but at the end of the day 80 20
still sets limitations around food
sometimes our days look a little more
like 20 than they do 80. and some days
it's more like a 50 50 split and both
are totally okay and normal ultimately
it really comes down to listening to
your body and honoring what it needs
without needing to do like a math
calculation in your head to determine
the ratio of vegetables or chocolate
that you're allowed to eat that day
that's good I love it
[Music]
slow cookers are a lazy girl's bestie so
they definitely come in clutch when you
are a busy mama and you maybe only have
a few minutes to chop up some veg but
not enough time to like labor over a
stovetop waiting for everything to cook
down so in this chicken soup we're
getting loads of veggies some carbs from
the potatoes and pasta noodles and some
protein in the chicken and of course I'm
a big fan of a hunger crushing dessert
which provides a ton of energizing carbs
from the dates so to sum this up what
are my thoughts on Sarah's Wellness week
well I appreciate any influencer who
promotes an idea of self-care that isn't
just a that girl routine and for someone
whose goal was just to spend 20 minutes
a day cooking a meal for herself she
pulled off a pretty impressive day of
eating from scratch good for Sarah but
for all of you watching at home just
struggling to like shower every day know
that I don't think that this is a
realistic goal for like 99 of us at home
I'm a YouTuber too and there is no way
in hell that I make three meals a day
from scratch and Vlog and bake every day
or like any day but again if it works
for Sarah and it feels like self-care to
her it absolutely works for me my issue
with this video is that there's a lot of
moralizing food language and also some
fear-mongering misinformation about
processed foods and I just don't think
that that helps anyone who are also just
trying to make baby steps toward Better
Health I would love to hear from you
guys about your definition of self-care
and the small little baby steps that
you've been taking on your own personal
Wellness journey and on that note that's
all that I have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on what you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]